I'm salad Li one night on the corner
here oh my god just like it just came
out of me like all those Road stories
yeah now I look back I don't I just like
a pro comic like a filthy male butt male
rotox are filthy filthy because you guys
clean up house afterwards what do you
mean after you want to get off stage a
funny dude that's so attractive to women
but no no no it wasn't even that now is
a weird disgusting world back then yeah
welcome to air it was a different era
the feature act yeah all right
so that's the best job and God it is 20
minutes I get offstage and I'm creepy by
the woman's bedroom thought you were
funny really
and there's another swallowing a sword
you will find it you don't know how many
ladies I'll pass over swallowing the
sword [ __ ] my hormone memoir titled suck
my sword on a Tuesday then come back to
the show on Friday with the husband
introduced me to the husband follow-up
title just crazy [ __ ] that it's really
crazy out there to digest it's
disgusting it's despicable what just a
web savage savage act of savagery it's
not yeah Sam I think I see I just think
I'm a bounty math seven I'm always been
approved like I'll go home the next one
and go what the [ __ ] happened last night
like why I gotta go I gotta talk to some
immigration like that type of crazy I
think a prude means that you don't do it
I think you do it they maybe feel over
Morse all please I really figured that
guilt all disgusting how are you raised
Catholic like a mother yeah that's right
and that don't think about a girl that
was married happily married I saw at the
park with her kids and one night I
played it in Fremont for both Chapman
[ __ ] I went to this party and she's
playing ping pong beat everybody
i buyed I waited I waited like a [ __ ]
possum and I got that I think ponder at
this she's telling me she likes to suck
dick let's play the pink bun when you
talk we would even you know you thinking
Paul is true legit Canela
like what are you ladies thinking today
does she not remember she lost to
somebody in ping-pong a second date yeah
wait who burn up the bed please tell me
was he asleep like the thing it must
have been told mrs. hen yeah who brought
the bed out that's a good question like
it had to be you it was like all right
if you win no no no yes fine thing poem
and she started talking about something
sucking dick hey Alyssa I send the
cameraman five in the morning were both
coked up [ __ ] it you lose you suck my
big one she won what'd she get I'm
thinking about it I gave her grandma
coke or something listen I know I wasn't
going to give again go to pray Lord that
was meanwhile she's gonna like me music
with a hit with the [ __ ] car you know
B does become Jason me and my coke
I'll back into that vision bolder
they'll blame another [ __ ] raccoon I
don't give a [ __ ] jack how seriously did
you take that game of ping-pong do we
like smile with her why listening how
are you like fourth cup I was playing in
a duct you have the sidewalk that was no
way I was losing my repo a little ooh
yeah I got a plan you gonna send me the
best Chinese grandson player in the [ __ ]
you were I think I'd be tiny
thanks for keeping fun they [ __ ]
everything up in everything my peoples
up in making bottle caps
well they did Chinese people to bring
baby pong like a bubble that's because
it's their name as well no no he's
[ __ ] crazy till this day I think
about what's that woman thinking she got
to be 50 like me and she's got to say I
lost a game of ping pong with punch and
suck the chubby dude's dick it was like
a half-ass comedian at the time living
as for the basement
ah I think she probably blacks I don't
think do people have like thinking about
that what if what if what happens is
every time she plays ping pong she ends
up sucking dick you mind you them can
you believe her like yeah sure she's
like I don't know I can't I don't know
what it is but I can't print I swallow a
sword